mai zusammen wir machen heute tacos und dieses
rezept ist so richtig ich kriege schon so einen
wässrigen mund wenn ich daran denke es einfach so
lecker knusprig ich mache hackfleisch guacamole
eine richtig leckeres salzer und wie einfach
das funktioniert das zeige ich euch jetzt
ich starte jetzt direkt mit der hackfleisch
füllung dafür habe ich vorab meine zwiebeln
schön fein gehackt ich habe euch alle ganz
genau wenn andré immer unten infobox und
jetzt gebe ich hier in meiner pfanne etwas
kokosfett das kritisch hin stark erhitzen
aber das ist desolat es riecht nach nichts und
es schmeckt auch noch nicht aber ihr könnt ist
schön heiß erhitzen und das verlange ich auch
in die infobox soll da gebe ich jetzt gleich
schon die zwiebeln mit dazu und auch meine
knoblauchzehen und anschließend kommt das
hackfleisch ich habe innerhalb fleisch kommt es
noch mit dazu und wird schön krümelig gebraten
besonders das anbraten dauert nur drei bis zehn
minuten ich habe danach auch schon passierte
tomaten dazugeben einfach damit sie so trocken
ist und die welt merken dass das fett austritt
und das ist so ein bisschen wässrig ist er räumt
aber schön cremig und fest und daher einfach ein
bisschen speisestärke dazu 77 ist deshalb wichtig
weil ihr sonst dicke klümpchen habt und das ist
dann nicht so schön also einfach da zu sehen
die welt merken das ist richtig schön sämig
wird jetzt wohl noch die gewürze dann nämlich
kreuzkümmel das ist für mich ein muss gebe ich
direkt mit dazu dann oregano paprikapulver und
ein bisschen chili und natürlich salz und pfeffer
so die hackfleisch masse ist fertig habe
den herd ausgeschaltet das ist einfach so
stehen und kümmere mich um die salsa dafür
also das ist wirklich ein schnelles als
sap dafür habe ich hier schön reife knackige
tomaten ich habe das vorher einmal gewaschen
und geputzt und die werde ich jetzt richtig
fein schneiden anschließend auch noch mit
zwiebel fein schneiden und eine chilischote
ich kann die so viel schlaf vertragen aber
wenn ihr mögt gibt die ganze rein ich
glaube ich ihm da nur eine halbe heute
alisa bruder intro hasst
jetzt kommt die gewürze da gebe ich dazu
kreuzkümmel ein bisschen braun und zucker
das passt super zu den tomaten natürlich salz
und pfeffer und anschließend noch olivenöl und
apfelessig als nächstes machen wir die
guacamole dafür avocado einmal vom stein
entfernt und in eine schüssel geben darin
könnt ihr sie dann ganz einfach mit einer
gabel richtig schön zu matschen und dann der
stelle gebe ich auch schon knoblauch mit dazu
ihm mehr als glaube ich ich liebe knoblauch
ich habe gibt es glaube ich fast überall dort
drin aber worauf ich definitiv verzichten werde
bei der burka mole also in ziegeln und tomaten
das mache ich sonst immer ganz gerne aber
wir haben jetzt hier schon zwiebeln in der
salza wir haben im up session zwiebel tomaten
haben wir auch und daher belastet ist dabei da
kommt gleich noch zitronensaft mit dazu salz
und pfeffer und dann ist auch schon fertig
die guacamole ist fertig ich habe hier noch die
kerne drin reingesteckt denn sie sollen helfen
dabei dass die halt ein bisschen später oxidieren
also dieses oxidieren der sonne luft führt er
dazu dass es dann zu brauen wie du nicht mehr so
schön aussieht ich habs jetzt mal versucht ist
das erste mal wir gucken mal ob es funktioniert
und meine mutter nimmt sogar die avocado kerne
trocknet sie raspelt sieht und macht sich da raus
und tee ist auch mal voll interessante könnte man
vielleicht auch mal versuchen so ich mache jetzt
hier noch ganz spontan eine käse soße heute gibt
es richtig food borne dafür stehe ich hier
am herd schalte den ein aber nicht zu hoch
denn jetzt gebe ich milch und sahne in meinem
kopf und wichtig ist das ist jetzt wirklich
nicht köchelt oder hoch kocht sondern wirklich nur
erwärmen dann den jetta käse darin quasi schmelzen
lassen und ich gebe da noch ein bisschen
edler süßes paprikapulver dazu pro fressen
unsere taktik bordeaux hamann ich habe übrigens
takko schalen gekauft bekannt doch selber machen
er warte ich schon selbst und auch erwärmt das
solltest du sie alles andere ist aber nicht
die zahlen sind auch direkt mal mit käse soße
hier merkt man kann diesen laxantien wenn man
sich den dreckig macht so viele fotos dieses
bisschen frost aber ich bin christ wird mir
richtig hell frisch witzig wird es perfekt haben
was da drin haben saarmund tag fleisch kammer
welcher wolke sieben dieser ist gelb aber ich
hätte ein bisschen besser machen können ehrlich
aber ein bisschen kannst du mal vertragen
das ist jetzt dass man wo kann
ich liebe ist liebe chor pole
richtig lecker also ich würde sagen macht jungen
die nach wenn hier gegen geschockte 1000 zu
verpassen möchte und dann lasst ein abo wenn das
nicht schon längst getan hat heute doppelt dabei
richtig feierlich ich könnte mir das noch
mal richtig vom tisch und so und entlassen
dann hab noch einen schönen tag